[Music]
[Music]
ah
china is their brothers it's being
dubbed
a game changer to pakistan's economic
and political future
a revival of the old silk road trade
route with more than
50 billion us dollars in investments
this is china's biggest overseas splurge
in
history with the building of power
plants
highways and ports all across the land
it's a chinese revolution in the islamic
republic of pakistan
as we traverse the length of this
gigantic economic collaboration
of the china-pakistan economic corridor
but before that lies the disputed
kashmir region
political instability and terrorism
before china can connect its xinjiang
province to the warm waters
of the arabian sea the iron brother
relationship
between pakistan and china a startling
new economic offensive by beijing
which is transforming forever the
economic
and political balance of south asia
[Music]
[Music]
beijing says the one belt one road is a
project of the century
a chinese-built infrastructure plan that
is remaking south asia
and the islamic republic of pakistan is
at the heart of
it chinese premier
xi jinping and pakistani president
hussein
inked beijing's flagship project in 2014
called the china-pakistan economic
corridor
it's a long-term plan to upgrade
pakistan's roads
railways and power generation and revive
its stagnating economy
[Applause]
despite years of terror-stricken
violence and political instability
pakistan is now being transformed on a
massive scale
higher than the himalayas deeper than
the seas
and sweeter than the sweetest honey this
is how china's friendship
has been eulogized by the pakistani
state
and china's new economic footprint here
changes
everything it's dotted with massive
chinese infrastructure projects
we begin our journey at the supreme
legislative body of pakistan
the parliament the strategic
relationship between the two countries
is decades old senator mushahid
hussain syed is well aware of china's
historical importance
to pakistan you must see this photograph
of mine with
president xi jinping this was on 21st
april 2015 when president xi jinping
came
he gave me a special award
as chairman of pakistan's parliamentary
committee on the china-pakistan economic
corridor
mushahid oversees all chinese-backed
projects in the country
you look very elegant it started off as
a project
and this is the largest comprehensive
project
between any two countries since world
war ii 46 billion dollars
for 15 years from 2015
to 2030. so it's a strategic project
there's investment in energy there is
government to government
relationship and infrastructure and
special industrial zone being
established
so at the same time in the history of
pakistan
such a scale of projects taken
concurrently is something unique and
unprecedented
next uh 10 to 15 years we expect that
over half a million jobs will be
generated it will add
to pakistan's 17 percent or 20 percent
to our gdp
and also it will spur at least two to
three percent
in a growth rate trade in this region
goes back
thousands of years we drive 600
kilometers to altit
a town that sprang up along the old silk
trade route
more than a thousand years ago according
to legend
altit was previously known as hunakuchal
meaning the village of huns the huns
came from the huangho valley in china
for trade with the middle east hundreds
of years ago
this village was surrounded by a huge
wall
with 11 strange towns
javid has been a tourist guide and
historian in altit
for the last 25 years
[Music]
the pre-history of silk route is 3000
years
[Music]
caravans of silk route travel from here
towards gilgit from gilgit to a store
from astor to sirinega and then they
will go to india
this was the shortest route of caravans
they were used uh donkey and horses and
in some areas they were used camels but
for the high
altitudes they would use yock
languages expertise artistic and
scientific skills
were discussed and traded right here as
they still are today
as maritime roots emerged this ancient
silk route near altit
lost its importance and fell into
neglect
until chinese premier xi jinping
announced 47 billion us dollars worth of
projects
over the next 15 years
this is china's biggest overseas
investment
ever the development of port cities like
wadar has been likened to that of the
marshall plan undertaken by the united
states
in post-war europe
from special economic zones in the south
near gwadar
it aims to industrialize large swaths of
pakistan
building logistical channels northwards
to the chinese city
of kashgar the industrialization of all
pakistani provinces
over the next 10 years aims to improve
and develop logistical corridors
establish business centers
and explore resources that can connect
to the southern chinese province of
xinjiang
in return the chinese are planning to
reduce their dependency on the south
china sea
for 80 percent of their trade from the
middle east
by cutting the travel time by 15 days
or 2 thousand miles and the backbone of
the china-pakistan economic corridor
is this road the karakoram highway
we drive from islamabad on the karakoram
highway
or kkh up north towards china
a 1 300 kilometer road
known as the eighth wonder of the world
the kkh was built by chinese and
pakistani workers
from 1959 and completed twenty years
later
locking these neighbors into a strategic
alliance in the region
above four thousand seven hundred meters
the construction was undertaken
in a treacherous terrain nearly 900
pakistani
and chinese workers died building the
strategic road
many of them were buried here at the
chinese cemetery
in gilgit when
[Music]
[Music]
pakistanis today remember their
sacrifices
with the korakorum highway xinjiang and
mainland pakistan
remain connected all year round for
trade
despite heavy snowfalls
due to this all-weather friendship the
china-pakistan economic corridor
has given hope to people like majeed
says
the entry point into pakistan from china
established in 1985 it's the first
trading port for
all passengers and cargo entering from
china
a 100 kilometers from the chinese border
this trading port
will be bustling with activity once cpec
is fully developed businessmen like aziz
ahmad
can already feel the difference his
goods have just arrived from china
i'm one of the importers who go to china
or
send their people to china they go to
different cities to guanzo
to urumchi they buy the consumer goods
from there according to the volume of
their own investment
chinese containers basically bring it
here they offload
all the goods here people from the
custom of course examine it
they calculate the duties and then we
clear our
goods from here from this port we load
them back in
pakistani trucks and we head back to our
destination
[Music]
this tripod can accommodate the
volume of trade that we expect from cpeg
because
it has been estimated that almost 7 000
containers will come from china under
cpa when this the whole project is
completed
so if we calculate our past capacity of
the sport we
hardly receive two to three thousand
containers during a whole year
exhaust is not just a strategic port for
pakistan
but also for the region
[Music]
china
they are also
as well as for china
due to the karakoram highway development
goods from
china that earlier took weeks can now
reach islamabad
in less than a day and locals estimate
that a chinese truck is expected to pass
along the karakoram highway
every 50 seconds the route is helping
retailers like malik naim
back in islamabad having worked in this
business for 13 years
naim has a reason to rejoice with the
opening up of the borders
under cpec
foreign
the rise in chinese investments is
changing the perception of pakistan
as a business friendly country i think
already pakistan's image as a country
which is infested with terrorism
violence i think that has changed
or is changing as an infester
friendly destination second it is
already spurring
growth in pakistan 5.3 the highest
growth in the last 10 years
but the sudden rise in chinese imports
by pakistani businessmen
is causing concern within the country
too
pakistan's trade deficit with its
largest trading partner china
widened to 6.2 u.s billion dollars in
2016.
[Music]
and that's not the only concern the
karakoram highway
is central to cpec success but can fall
prey
to mother nature an earthquake in 2010
led to an entire mountainside falling
into the hunza river
and destroying part of the kurokom
highway
[Music]
the chinese stepped in to the rescue
there's been an avalanche of chinese
investments across pakistan
in rail ports construction and energy
and i'm traveling on the karakoram
highway a land route
to be used by the chinese to connect
xinjiang
to gwadar port in the south it's a
highway
that's been struck by natural calamities
in 2010 an earthquake pushed an entire
mountain
into the hunsar river blocking it
permanently
the landslide killed 20 people at this
village of atabat
and displaced 6000 people in gojal
village
on the karakoram highway the pakistan
army was called in
to clear the blockage but failed despite
all the heavy machinery
the river swelled into a lake now called
the atabad lake
yasir remembers those days as he takes
us to his former home
on a wooden boat basically
starting
[Music]
um
pakistan and china had no road
connection for five months
as the lake continued to expand wooden
boats
costing forty dollars a trip were the
only way to cross the lake to maintain
trade and communication the ferries were
not designed to carry cargo like this
and the trips were full of risk this
very basic means of transportation
caused delays leading to a hike in
commodity prices
[Music]
so
the chinese were called in to rebuild
the karakoram highway
this time cutting directly through the
mountains
[Music]
in less than two years a series of
tunnels were carved through the
treacherous terrain
in partnership with pakistan's national
highway authority
and the china road and bridge
corporation today
they are known as the pakistan china
friendship tunnels
what used to take an hour to cross by
boat
now takes only five minutes
yasir and his family now live near the
lake in their makeshift home
they can now enjoy a meal without paying
exorbitant prices
to the boat riders
another direct result from these tunnels
has been a rise in tourism
in the mountainous region 600 000 local
and international tourists visited
pakistan's northern mountains
in 2016. a lack of basic infrastructure
however
is hampering growth as night falls in
gilga
the hub of tourism blackouts ranging
from eight to ten hours
are the norm and afzal a hotelier
feels the full brunt of the impact
[Music]
but there's a new sun rising in pakistan
private companies from china are tapping
into the country's energy potential
with 11 billion us dollars of
investments
to satisfy the demand under the
china-pakistan economic corridor
power plants producing 10 000 megawatts
of electricity
are being installed in nuclear coal and
hydro-powered stations
across the nation gilget's potential in
hydropower
is unmatched due to the fast-flowing
hunza river
gilgit baltistan is the water bank for
the rest of the country
because you know our area is more than
72 000 square kilometers
and more than 27 percent of this
catchment area
consists of glaciers which is the
biggest
concentration of glaciers outside polar
regions
so overall we have a capacity of
more than 60 000 megawatts of hydropower
potential
the phenomena of cpec is that most of
the projects are in b2b
mode the chinese business community
comes to pakistan and invests
in collaboration with the business
community of pakistan in renewable
energies
hydro power is the most desirable one
because it is clean
it does not have carbon emissions
however
one time investment is huge hydro plants
in difficult mountainous terrains
are being built the naltel power plant
is an 18 megawatt plant that feeds off
the vast energy potential
of the northern pakistani region chief
engineer
gulam murtaza is confident of the
growing collaboration with the chinese
in the power sector commercial
[Music]
more than 35 000 people in gilgit will
get power from this particular power
plant
when you are going to convert this
chinese that goes into english
is working closely with a private
chinese company
whose workers are monitoring its
developments
i mean
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you pakistan remains a solid market
for private chinese companies with the
advent of cpec
but the security challenges in the
troubled province of balochistan
are immense none more so than for the
jewel
of the chinese investment in pakistan
the new megaport city
of gwadar china's economic corridor
is transforming pakistan's stagnant
economy
it's taking 50 billion us dollars to do
just that it's one of the fastest and
the biggest project
on the one belt one road initiative
china has now the world's second biggest
economy and it's growing at a fast pace
it's almost seven percent per year so if
you look at the map of the world
if china is ex importing energy from the
middle east from
africa you're talking of going through
the straits of malacca
you're going through the south china sea
to shanghai to tianjin
it's about 9 000 kilometers if you go
through
gowada then it's about 3000 kilometers
so you have slashed it by two-thirds so
number one is
easy access the larger goal
is a framework of regional connectivity
through trade
amongst countries and the jewel of this
economic crown
is gwadar launched with much fanfare by
former prime minister
nawaz sharif gawadar is undergoing
rapid development china leased the port
for 40 years
and 91 of the revenue generated will
head
back to beijing there are benefits to
pakistan too
from being a fishing village 15 years
ago it is now estimated
that the gwadar port development will
create 700 000 jobs
its geostrategic importance is crucial
the rapid progress in developing the
megaport has been eyed with concern
by india it has forged a rival 20
billion us dollar plan with iran
to expand iran's chabahar port
100 kilometers along the coast the basic
issue is that india sees
itself as a sort of a rival and they
will try to play that role
india is today where china was 15 years
ago
so there's a sea change this big
yearning chasm
between india's level of development and
china's development
china is decades ahead of india so i
think instead of trying to compete
unnecessarily
they should be part of that
compatibility
so what's the problem with india so you
see the a whole new opportunity is
opening up
and if you link gwadar with cha bahar
and iran
with hambun tota in sri lanka in kyokpo
in myanmar so you can see that
a whole new world is opening up of
connectivity
the wadar is expected to attract 3
trillion u.s dollars of trade
per year due to chinese imports
it's sitting on the face of the straits
of hormuz
the busiest oil trading route in the
world
the development of gwadar has been
inspired by the singapore model
i took the parliamentary committee on
the china-pakistan economic corridor on
a visit to china
and i especially asked that we should go
to sujoo which is the
first industrial park between singapore
and china and that was established
in 1990s after the visit of deng
xiaoping to singapore and it had a
meeting with lee kuan yew
and that he was so inspired by that and
he felt that this is the way forward so
they established the first industrial
park in china was with singapore and
singapore is a good model because
singapore has no natural resources
singapore has human resources
and pakistan's strength is also as human
capital
and that is what we want to focus on
[Music]
a major difference between the two
countries though lies in the security
challenges the province of baluchistan
poses
balochistan is the least developed
province in pakistan
despite its rich mineral resources
islamabad has exploited that mineral
wealth but the province remains
underdeveloped
it has led to five armed uprisings by
local ethnic groups
since the territory joined pakistan in
1948
[Music]
addressing chinese fears the pakistan
army
has raised a 15 000 strong cpec force
to protect its engineers and investments
the importance of maritime domain which
includes sea
and its approaches is critical
to safe operationalization
it is in this framework that raising of
task force
88 for maritime security of the cpac
finds its anchorage the remaining land
route
is to be patrolled and policed by a cpec
force
with more than 300 police officials
currently being hired
in the gilgit region
[Music]
officer johar is one such officer
protecting a section of the karakoram
highway
as chinese containers pass through it
at least 25 such cpec patrol vehicles
have been given to gilgit police
by china aid they are to ensure the safe
and smooth flow of traffic day and night
on the 439 kilometer chunk of the cpec
route in gilgit
foreign
foreign
[Music]
with an increase in chinese influence a
cultural exchange is underway
in pakistan too
this is roots a private school in the
federal capital
of islamabad from classes 1 to 10
students attend compulsory mandarin
classes
with the aim of familiarizing them with
the next big economy
someone somebody
in 2016 3 500 pakistani students studied
in china
making pakistan the country with the
largest number of scholarship
students studying in china mona
the head of the chinese language school
is upbeat about this exchange of
cultures
we have a collaboration with cri
confucius
institute in fact we are the first
official confucius classroom in pakistan
we've got about 12 full-time teachers
who are teaching chinese language to the
students
and at the moment there are 8500
students learning
this language so yes there is
a lot of future for these students when
it comes to the working environment
yet when they're going to get into their
practical lives they'll be able to
work in pakistan because of the cpac and
because you know
chinese people there are many huawei and
such chinese companies working around
so students will have all the
opportunities to work in pakistan as
well as in china
mandarin teacher yang came to islamabad
two years ago from sichuan
to teach mandarin to pakistani students
i have been teaching these kids for
almost two years
and first of all i think i want to see
the pakistani people are extremely
friendly to chinese people
because every time when you go outside
they will say oh chinese chinese
yes and there is about industry in davao
pak china friendship
yeah a long life park china friendship
and uh i think the kids were to
have a very good desire to know chinese
no every time we don't have chinese
class every day but
many times students will find me come to
teach us
come to teach us i want to know chinese
yes
shamam a grade 7 student is one of the
brightest mandarin students
at the school
[Music]
we're learning chinese it's the language
of the 21st century and i think it's
important and it's a really big
opportunity for all of us kids over here
that we are able to have such a good
staff through which we can learn
proper dialect of chinese you know
because
china is the next big deal
you know america okay great any other
country
great you know but china is
they're brothers you know to be very
frank they're their neighbors their
brothers and they've you know
been very helpful for the
country too very close the ties are good
as well so
definitely and the people are great too
the people are great too the food is
great as well
along with mandarin students at root
school
are exposed to chinese arts and
performances as well you have to breathe
naturally
okay along with yang chinese language
teachers
have been living and working in
islamabad for years
[Music]
i think it's very comfortable yes
now more and more chinese in chinese
people are coming to pakistan
to investment to visit to travel yes
to do many other things and
i also i was so many pakistani people
going to china and the teachers feel
safe despite the common perception of
pakistan
to the contrary they drive us back to
their apartment
for a little cooking session
[Music]
they feel comfortable living here so
then more chinese come in
now after these teachers there are more
teachers coming in just because they
know that you know
they're living safe over here they have
a good environment they have a good
stay a rise in chinese cultural
influence
is having a damaging effect on
pakistan's own heritage
in the 5 000 year old city of lahore a
mass transit metro project
is threatening the very heritage of
pakistan
itself if this train is allowed to go
ahead
unesco has said that this building will
fall within six years
scores of power projects have been inked
thousands of miles of roads are being
built
the chinese have arrived in pakistan
with their customary trademark style
billions of dollars worth of energy and
infrastructure
are being constructed by chinese firms
and the chinese are growing their
footprint with each passing day
i've arrived in the city of lahore known
as the heart of pakistan
in a city of 10 million its people are
vibrant
colorful but a lack of functional public
transport system
has transformed the city of gardens into
one
big traffic jam
enter the chinese pakistan's first ever
metro train a 1.6 billion u.s dollar
gift
from the people of china is being built
at breakneck speed
in less than two years the project will
have built
26 stations hamad
the project director and the local
partner for this chinese finance cpec
project is excited
[Music]
developed
[Music]
chinese firms norinko designed and
constructed the metro system
with the help of habib construction and
the lahore development authority
it's an early bird cpec project nearing
completion
and the
[Music]
complications
[Music]
the train running on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign the focus
has been on hardware projects like the
lahore metro
complications arose when the lahore
conservation movement
moved the lahore high court to stop the
project from destroying
lahore's rich mughal cultural heritage
chaburji meaning four towers is a 16th
century mughal era building
that lies on the root of the metro train
activist imrana tiwana claims the punjab
state government
launched the project in haste without
altering the route
to protect the historical icon from
train vibrations
if this train is allowed to go ahead
unesco has said that this building will
fall within six years
imrana tiwana claims the metro passes
less than 200 feet
from protected heritage sites a blatant
violation
of pakistani law this project is
a national disaster and i speak only on
technical terms and i will talk about
the facts
it is passing through the densest
heritage
zones of the city and it is
threatening to cause irreversible and
permanent damage to
the heritage of lahore lahore will be
dead i think we can write the epitaph
this project is violating all the local
laws and the
unesco convention which is really a
great
humiliation for pakistan it is
threatening
over 40 heritage sites we call it a
heritage zone where the train is passing
i think there are two very distinct laws
the special premises preservation
ordinance
and the uh antiquities act both of them
explicitly say that there can be no
construction
of any kind in fact you can't even put a
banner or a nail up
within 200 feet of any
antiquity site or a special premises
the lahore high court has stopped all
construction of the metro
close to the heritage sites until the
case is settled
kwaja hassan the head of punjab state
government's metro project
says he's done everything he can to
placate the concerns of the activists
the issues which have been uh which have
cropped up as you know
is because of the certain heritage
buildings heritage points where
we are in the courts we are i mean
defending our side
because we strongly feel that heritage
is very important
and our government our chief executive
has been very focused on this that we
have to take care of our heritage points
our focus has been on uh public mass
transit
uh and the purpose is uh very i mean
it's very obvious
see with the growing population the
growing need of
more transportation this was one of the
focuses of
our government everywhere in the world
wherever you go go to rome or any of the
major cities which are old ancient
cities they do have heritage but they do
have a very very massive mass transit
system
and they're all moving and going all
about it
just next to the heritage points
so they've done it and they've achieved
it so we are facing this challenge
because it's happening for the first
time in pakistan's history
so it's a very challenging task and we
are grateful to the government of china
for
giving us providing us uh great
assistance
on this the delay in construction
is causing losses to both the chinese
and their pakistani counterparts
which raises the question of financing
building a 1.6 billion us dollar train
in a country where people find it
difficult to eat
has been vehemently criticized financed
by china's exim bank
and undertaken by the punjab government
expensive projects like the lahore metro
may lead pakistan into a debt trap with
china
former finance minister salman shah is
cautious about how prepared pakistan
is for the scale of development deals it
is now committing to
financing is going to be tough
but i think it can be managed provided
we
we negotiate the terms of the agreements
very well and are able to get the
financing which is
competitive but not expensive so i think
that should be the
nature of the agreements and i think
from even the two government's
perspective they would probably like
that also
but to my mind we as pakistanis
have not yet been able to articulate
the full dimensions of cpac the how
important it is to our overall
national economic development and
economic strategy
we have not yet integrated it into
our decision-making processes and
planning processes and involvement of
the private sector
fully into this apart from trade and
connectivity
there's a larger issue for chinese
investors in pakistan
political instability no prime minister
in pakistan's 70-year history
has completed a five-year term and this
time
was no different former prime minister
sharif was disqualified from office in
july 2017
by a supreme court verdict after he was
found guilty
of corruption in a show of power to his
political opponents
sharif organized rallies like this
throughout pakistan
causing fears the country might unravel
politically
a new prime minister of his own party
was quickly elected
to quell any fears
completely
a television presenter of gotv and one
of the foremost names of pakistani
journalism
doesn't find prime minister sharif
ousting alarming to the chinese
a prime minister has been deposed
through a judicial verdict
and he is protesting against that
verdict but you don't see any violence
on the streets the elections around the
corner in 2018 may be called
early so there's a lot of political
hyperactivity but
it has remained within the bounds of the
constitution so that way it's stable
and uh all the parties that are locking
horns
they agree on cpac i mean there's no
disagreement on on cpac
we are a deceptive nation in the sense
that what appears
may not be the case you know when we
look kind of down and out
uh somehow we bounce back when we look
kind of all hyped up we're
actually cool cool as cucumbers but
without sort of blowing our own trumpet
i think pakistan is a country whose
geography
has taken it to various directions we
also now realize that the same geography
can be harnessed
to become a trade route to become an
export and import zone
to become a pathway through which the
world's commerce actually passes
i think that's where we are headed
towards if that were to happen and
that's why cpec is important
i think we have a fairly interesting
future that lies ahead interesting in
the american sense not in the chinese
sense
tonight marks the 70th year of
pakistan's
independence from india despite many
wars with him
children men and women are out in the
streets to celebrate
it's a young nation with more than 75
under the age of 25 and it has been
marked as one of the next
11 big economies to look out for
the avalanche of chinese investments
might just do the trick for pakistan
there are a number of major challenges
to be overcome
for this iron brother relationship to be
fully realized economically
but the dream of the china-pakistan
economic corridor
is fast becoming a reality
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Music]
you